I'm a big fan of Treyon he's talented as  hell Underdog small all of that but  because of his stature you're going to  want to like him before you want to hate  him and I personally think Trey has in  his mind he's taken on this villain role  he's good enough to take it on  and still play well and still be Trey  young and still be an All-Star and be  fine but I personally think it's the  wrong approach because being a villain  ain't fun you only get so much out of  tell us like  I out of shutting someone up and so I  think  like for a guy like Trey nah man go the  opposite way but you're saying like  almost don't intentionally make life  harder exactly